there were a whole bunch of awesome
announcements at Google i/o 2019 but my
personal favorite is definitely firebase
performance for the web well today we're
expanding performance monitoring to the
web this is a tool that can benefit any
website that cares about performance
even if that site isn't already using
other firebase products by simply adding
a script tag to your site or including
firebase perf in your JavaScript bundle
you'll get insights about how your web
app performs out in the real world in
terms of initial page load performance
and HTTP calls over the network in
today's video we'll look at the basics
of firebase performance and take things
a few steps further by implementing our
own custom traces and we'll look at some
awesome upcoming features in angular
fire to integrate with angular and rxjs
if you're new here like and subscribe
and make sure to download the mobile app
on iOS or Android to take the firebase
performance quiz after you're done
watching this video now there's a few
different ways we can use firebase
performance the most basic way is to use
it as just a standalone tool in an
existing website this approach will
insert a lightweight script into your
HTML document and then you'll
automatically get all kinds of
performance reporting on the firebase
console so this is a great option if you
have an existing website and you want
some performance reporting but you don't
want to use any other fighter based
products the next option is to use it in
combination with firebase hosting if
you're already using firebase hosting
you can use these magic script tags to
easily import it into your project but I
think the vast majority of people will
use it in combination with a module
bundle or like web pack that's how we're
going to use it today in the context of
an angular application but the process
is very similar for all JavaScript
frameworks the first thing I want to do
is install the latest version of
firebase making sure that it's version
6.0 or greater now most of the code that
we'll look at is relevant to any
JavaScript app but at the end of the
video we're going to look at some really
cool new bleeding edge stuff from the
angularfire library at the time of this
video you can use it by installing an
angular fire with the next tag from
there you'll want to go to the firebase
console and go to the Settings tab and
you'll see an option to now add your app
as a web app you'll want to do this even
if you have an existing app because
there's a new property that you need to
have in your firebase config in order to
work with firebase performance that
property is the app ID which you can see
down here at the bottom and if you go to
the performance screen you should see
your web app there as an option and keep
in mind it can take up to 24 hours for
the data to populate so don't be worried
if you don't see any data after
deploying initially I was lucky enough
to be able to test firebase
performance before it was officially
released so I have quite a bit of data
built up here for fire ship IO the
actual data that you see on the
dashboard is similar to what you would
see on a lighthouse performance score
that you run locally in your Chrome
browser except this data is being
collected and segmented across all your
users in the real world on the dashboard
I can see the aggregate performance for
things like first paint first contentful
paint
dominar active and how they're
distributed across the entire user base
by looking at this distribution I can
see that the majority of my users are
seen page load times in less than two
seconds so that's pretty good but I'm
always pushing new code to my web app so
what if I do something that makes the
performance decline
I can easily determine if my performance
is getting better or worse by looking at
the trend over time ideally you want to
see this chart have a negative slope
because faster is always better and on
top of that we can filter this data by
region by device and even whether or not
the user has a service worker installed
this allows us to figure out what users
are being affected by a performance
bottleneck and what the root cause might
be in addition to page loads it will
also keep track of HTTP calls over the
network so if you have some sort of
async activity that's causing a
performance bottleneck you'll be able to
find it here now everything I've showed
you so far will just work out of the box
when you include firebase performance in
your app but you can also write your own
custom traces within your apps code and
that opens the door to all kinds of cool
possibilities for example I have a
custom trace here on a log in modal that
users click to log into the app and this
allows me to see exactly how long it
takes a user on average to log into the
app but one thing I do want to point out
at this point is that you should never
use any personally identifiable
information inside of a trace things
like email addresses or phone numbers
not only is that a bad practice for a
user privacy but Google will flag it for
automatic deletion anyway we'll be
writing our own custom traces in just a
minute and once you've collected some
data you'll have a screen that looks
like this that you can filter by
different attributes you can even create
your own custom attributes in your code
and you can also set up your own custom
thresholds to signify a certain point
that a metric would be considered poor
performance in my case I've already
gotten valuable insight from this trace
because I found out that users on Safari
take way longer to login than users on
Chrome or Firefox and the reason I
detected that is because firebase is
smart enough to warn me about it with
this little orange icon here so it'll
automatically tell you when a certain
segment seems out of the ordinary and
that's all based on real world data from
fire ship let's go ahead and jump into
the code
right our own custom traces back in our
angular app we'll go into the app module
and then set up the firebase config
making sure that it contains the app ID
I've already included fire store and
angularfire auth in here and then we can
go ahead and include the angular fire
performance module this setup is
specific to angular
but the traces that we'll write next our
framework agnostic there's a lot of
different use cases for firebase
performance depending on what you're
interested in tracking and the component
we'll go ahead and import firebase from
firebase app and then initialize
firebase performance on iOS and Android
fire perf will automatically track how
long a screen has been opened but we can
also do that in a single page
application by using the lifecycle hooks
in the framework now the trace itself
you can think of like a stopwatch you
create an instance of a trace with a
specific name then you call start to
start it and stop to end it a simple
trace will just keep track of the
elapsed time but we can also add custom
attributes and metrics in between as
we'll see later so in this case here
we'll start our trace during ng on init
and then we'll end the trace during ng
on destroy and now I'll have an
understanding of exactly how much time
our users are spending on the login page
so that represents your most simple use
case for a custom trace but there's a
whole lot we can do in between the start
and stop point let's go ahead and add a
custom trace into the auth logic itself
first by injecting angularfire auth into
the constructor and then we'll create an
async function here called login and
this is the function that we would call
after the user submits a form with their
email and password the first thing we'll
do is create an instance of a trace
called user login and start it then stop
it at the end of the function and add a
try-catch block in between the start and
stop point what we'll try to do is login
the user with email and password and if
that's successful then we'll want to put
a custom attribute that will tell us
whether or not the user has a verified
email address this example is kind of
trivial but attributes are just strings
that allow you to segment your data in
different ways setting really good
attributes will result in really good
performance reporting on the firebase
console now if there's an error in the
process we can go in here to catch and
we'll set a different attribute called
error code that will allow us to segment
by different error codes in the firebase
console as well so if there's a certain
browser quirk that makes it really hard
for users to log in with email and
password we should be able to detect it
with this trace and really just be able
to see how smooth our login process is
in general so that's how you create
custom attributes to segment the data
but you can also add your own custom
metrics for reporting
would actually show up as numeric values
on your performance reports let's
imagine we have a function here that
loads user data that makes multiple
queries to different buyers store
collections and we want to know how long
that query takes and also how many
documents are read in the process this
time I'll be using angular fighter'
directly so this codes a little more
specialized to angular but basically
we're just reading a collection of items
but we don't know how many items are in
that collection after the read is
complete we'll call trace increment
metric and we'll set a metric as total
size that will keep track of the total
size of all reads that we perform in
this function but we can also create
another metric that's just based on the
size of the items collection only if we
want to do that we can call trace put
metric and this will add a metric to
this trace that doesn't really change
over the life cycle the trays so
increment metric is really useful when
you have data that might change like
incrementing the score on a game or
something like that
in our case here we'll read from another
collection called things and then this
time we'll use the total size of that
collection to increment our total size
metric so if there were 10 documents in
the first query and then 15 documents in
the second query our total value would
be 25 for this particular trace now I
like this code for an async function but
if this were an observable it means we
would have to pipe in the tap operator
all over the place to start and stop the
trace but thankfully James Daniels who's
the lead maintainer of angularfire has
put in some work to make this a lot
easier especially for angular rxjs
developers if you're working in angular
you're much more likely to be reading
collections in the context of an
observable your most basic use case
would just be to pipe in this
performance trace operator and then give
it a name and that will automatically
give you the latency of a collection
read you don't even need to call start
or stop because it automatically knows
to do that when you subscribe to the
observable in this case it will
automatically stop the trace when the
observable emits data but there's also
several more operators in there that
allow you to handle more advanced use
cases
my favorite is trace until this allows
you to set up a trace but only stop the
trace when a certain condition has been
met for example say you have a game
running and then you're making multiple
updates to that document based on the
state of the game once the GAMEOVER
property is set to true then it ends the
trace here and then there's also a third
option for trace options that allow you
to do things like set attributes and
metrics like we did before so overall
this is a very promising update for
angular fire but more importantly
firebase performance is pretty much a
no-brainer for every app
it's free easy to set up lightweight and
it will help you catch problems that you
didn't even know existed I'm gonna go
ahead and wrap things up there if this
video helped you please like and
subscribe and if you want even more
content consider becoming a pro member
at fire ship IO and don't forget to take
the quiz on the fire ship mobile app to
see if you learned anything thanks for
watching and I will talk to you soon
[Music]